i'm really really close with my
classmates specifically
you know oscar and and daisy and myself
and kelly had
really transparent loving conversations
that i will never forget for the rest of
my career
as individuals we have impossible back
[Music]
as a collective we stand a chance
john first of all what was it like
playing this role at a time where it is
so significant to everything that's
going on in this universe and trying to
show that
there are people out there trying to
make a change but it's so damn hard
i think it points uh an alarming eye at
the fact that this will always be
a prominent issue because we actually
filmed it before
any of the the prominent stories that we
we all know today we
actually filmed it when when things were
were more centered in
other issues um so to know that it kind
of like
fizzled into this it's like a prophecy
position
from steve mcqueen for pending this idea
and for them getting me involved
did you know that leroy logan sawyer was
there was saw your um speech in the park
during the black lives
matter rally yeah yeah yeah i i actually
um
i actually saw a bunch of people and my
sister actually told me that yo
like she follows libra on instagram and
she said that uh yeah
leroy was there and i was like well i
didn't i didn't know it was good that he
was around
what was it like when you saw yourself
that you were trending worldwide and
black folks were like
around the world were like yo john
boyega all right
you know like people really felt it you
know what i mean
yeah i mean you know i'm i i feel it's
just
just me expressing how how i feel about
certain issues i just feel like
it probably hit at a time where people
can relate and
a lot of people in that position would
have probably said you know the same
thing
so it's always good to have someone just
that has a a stage and a position to be
able to
speak from a very true perspective and
it was an honor to be able to do that
for you
how things change in the uk did leroy
logan make a difference
he did and he can and he continues to do
so what was
funny the first time i met leroy logan
actually went there with her with a
friend
and as soon as she saw leroy she was
just like wait he mentored me
like he he mentored me with a lot of
young people
in the area i grew up with in pekka and
brixton campbell
he's done a lot of work and he's um
known for
for basically his success rate at
showing people that it can be done
hey in that great gq um interview you
did you talked about your experience in
star wars being different from other
cast members because
you were a man of color and um how was
that received by your castmates how did
they
take that full support full support um i
got a text message from
from daisy i mean we talk we talk all
the time so
but to be fair we i'm really really
close with my classmates specifically
you know oscar and and daisy and myself
and kelly had
really transparent loving conversations
that i will never forget for the rest of
my career
so we were all already speaking about
things you know so
this me saying this wasn't really a bit
of a shock to them but they
they did text me to say they support me
how important was it that you said i
mean
we on the outside realize the importance
of you stepping up to say
something like that and to say what you
said in the park but how scary was that
for you
knowing that you know there are people
out there who may take that the wrong
way and say oh
well i'm done with this dude yeah man i
and i understand that because you know
the narrative
you know as i said no one's ever going
to assume that i'm you know telling the
truth right it's hard for people to even
see things are positive and i understand
that um
but i don't care you know one must
always uh talk about things so that in
moving on
perhaps because i have now come out with
this for the next actor being in that
position
that's now not going to be an alien
conversation there is al
there's always another actor who made
that topic prominent
to refer to to help have those
conversations in these spaces
and also you know many people of
industry have reached out
um to have these transparent
conversations
um and and and that has really really
helped will you do another star wars
would you do another star wars
i don't know i've always said i don't
know i don't know what's going on with
star wars i think um
well i'm alive that's that's that's what
that's one thing but we'll just depend
on story and it will depend whether
daisy and oscar you know are coming back
i wouldn't want to be riding around by
myself or anything
[Music]
[Applause]
how important was it doing these stories
was what steve is doing
and telling these stories and bringing
them to life and giving you an
opportunity
to bring them to the screen to share
with other people
i think it's so important storytelling
is can sometimes be revolutionary in
terms of exposing different perspective
that you may
have not looked into um although it's
dramatized and we can
never convey the absolute truth because
you have to sit through someone's life
um that can help prompt research more
intricate and critical
critical dialogue and i just think he's
very very important in this process as
we decide
you know what we're fighting for or what
we support and and
and how we morally approach these kind
of scenarios that we're seeing in the
world today
you are fighting for things that are
happening all around the world but
including in nigeria and you've been
very vocal about that and how important
is that
to stay on top of what's going on there
because people don't understand
they look at london they look at america
and they forget about africa
yeah well i live a unique experience um
i'm i'm actually a nigerian citizen i
have uh dual citizenship so here here in
the uk and in nigeria
and i go back a lot go back frequently i
love nigeria i've actually worked in
nigeria
as well and spent so much time there i
love the people my loved ones are over
there in several different states
so to see nigeria going through this
change and revolution
for me is is is so important for those
of us that are in comfort
to lend our voice um because if we don't
if we stay silent then who are we
truly and who are we as as people truly
and can we say that we are truly people
who can convey love
if we don't know how to speak out when
our own people back home are suffering
in this way
so it's just what we have to do amen as
you were marching
because that was your first protest ever
as you're marching with the folks and
now they're realizing
oh my god john boyega is out here with
us what was that moment like
for you to be amongst the people with
them and knowing that
your message meant so much to so many
people yeah it meant it meant a lot to
me because you know
the the illusion of of fame and
and money and stability people feel
why would he care about us you know
you're good you're made you've done it
why would you care um and it's good
through action
to always break down those obstacles so
we can always identify our true allies
people who truly have our backs and for
me to be in that position to be there
with those people marching i'm just
essentially one body
in a massive group but to have that
influence to be able to push their
message
for me it's just it's just a good thing
to do and i'm you know i'm glad that god
used me for that still
how important is it that michael b
jordan has started this company that has
the um
it's doing black superheroes what do you
think of that
like michael b jordan is doing very very
well we've actually i've actually
been in talks with members of his team
outlier society
uh and i've actually seen him go through
a growth that i feel like is incredible
i think him making this move is dope he
is a a comic book fan
as well um something that's going to do
a very good job of it and that's
he's got on we've got a nerd on on side
to make this uh
static shock movie gulp
you